[Music]
so the title of this talk is making
WebGL dance and that's because linear
algebra isn't as sexy on a schedule but
the talk isn't so much about WebGL
directly as it is about graphics
hardware and how it works because this
could be making OpenGL dance or direct3d
all these principles kind of apply and
so my remote is not working just sick
here we go so I'd like to talk about
three things how to draw where to draw
and what to draw which is sort of the
the mental model of how you should think
about what a graphics card does and
where it comes from as opposed to doing
sort of yet another WebGL 101 how to
draw a cube and make it move because
well that teaches you you know how to
use WebGL and how to use the API it kind
of ends up being a dead end because
you're not quite sure what's going on
and once you get into more advanced
stuff if there's a bug or an issue you
don't know what to do so the good news
is however everything I'm going to be
talking about is really stuff that you
should understand but not necessarily
know how to implement yourself because
the graphics hardware does it for you
it's convenient so even though there's
gonna be a lot of techniques and all
that you don't be worried about it
because you just you know type the
command or set the thing to true to get
that effect going the bad news is
there's going to be four dimensions and
I'm not going to apologize about that
because it's cool and the thing is you
know this is mathematics but we
shouldn't be afraid of it we should
embrace it what this means in this case
is this just a fourth number where
before there used to be only three and
it has some interesting consequences so
let's get started in the beginning there
was pixels and pixels were fun but no
that's not true there was a vector
graphics first but we'll forget about
that pixels there was something called
brezin hemlines and that was fun because
using a simple for loop you could just
color in pixels and draw lines and once
we figured out how to do that we could
even draw solid shapes using something
like scanline rendering to draw a
triangle like this
unfortunately if you try to for example
make a spinning triangle with the
technique it doesn't so much rotate as
tick why does it tick why does it look
bad well it's because we're snapping to
pixels everything we've done is we've
defined our graphics operations in terms
of the pixel grid which means we can
only move the corners in this fashion
how do we solve this well if you know a
little bit about graphics you may be
thinking of the word anti-aliasing no
that's something else because look at
this beautifully anti-aliased triangle
that's still jerking around in an ugly
fashion what we actually want is
something called sub pixel accuracy
which looks like this where even though
you know it's alias there's only black
and white and there's jaggies it's
moving smoothly and I can put the
corners of the shape anywhere I want how
exactly does this work because it's not
obvious anymore where exactly the the
edges on the pixel grid start or end
when the the pixel in the corner
actually should be black when it's
partially covered etc and the key is
something called sampling or using
samples where whether a pixel is black
or white is actually just defined by one
thing which is the point right in the
middle so at that point is inside the
triangle we color the pixel black
otherwise we color it white and this
might not seem like an important concept
but it really is because it defines
everything that follows and that's kind
of why I'm talking about it first
because what this means is there's
really two worlds on the left hand you
have the world of vectors where you know
everything is mathematical and beautiful
your shapes are mathematically defined
and then you use sampling to transfer it
over to the world on the right which is
the raster world the world of pixels and
you really have to think of this sort of
as a final step and the reason is
because when you actually look at this
diagram on the left hand side those
samples are in the middle of every pixel
and that means the edges of the pixel
grid don't actually exist in vector
world there's sort of an artifact of the
rasterization if you will and in fact we
describe this as a nearest neighbor
filter where you know the when we try to
turn this grid of samples back into
something continuous we just assign the
color of the nearest
people to that area and the fact that
the pixels come out square is kind of
just an artifact of that is not good of
the where the samples are placed and and
so this is ugly and pixelated a better
ways for example to use a bilinear
filter where you you add gradients
between pixels to sort of even it out
and what's important about this diagram
is that the color information is not
again on the only edges of the pixel
grid it's in the middle and so the edges
of the pixel are kind of a distraction
data they don't factor in here so what
actually is anti-aliasing and an
aliasing
for well it's this in this case I'm
taking a texture of white and of gray
and black and looking at in perspective
and it's being sampled and you can see
in the distance there's all this noise
and blurring is going on and the reason
that happens is because when you sample
you can only pick one or the other
either gray or black what it actually
should look like is something like this
where the further you go into the
distance the the more blurred out and
gray it gets because you know the
projection of a single pixel on the
screen now covers a wide area far far
far in the distance look at a liasing a
bit closer has to do with something
called a sampling theorem and the
Nyquist frequency where if you take this
pattern of bars and you can press it you
get to this point where it goes white
black white black white black
alternating and you try to compress it
further it starts to get messed up in
fact it folds in on itself and does
something weird running that backwards
you can see you approach the Nyquist
frequency white black white white black
and then it expands smoothly again so
what that means is you can't compress
any more variation onto the pixel grid
then that particular frequency because
there's no room for it and so the fact
that you get jaggies when you're trying
to draw shapes is really an artifact of
aliasing and instead of thinking again
of the pixel edges you need to look at
the slopes here because because of the
pixel grid there
maximum slope between white and black
that we can we can represent with this
information and that's really where the
problem lies it has very little to do
with
jaggies which is what most people think
of when they talk about anti-aliasing so
what is anti-aliasing isn't blurring all
the things sort of it's blurring it in a
specific way what you're actually doing
is you're determining how much of your
shape covers every pixel and then
shading the the pixel proportionately
and so you can do that mathematically
using the rules of geometry to get an
exact result but that's kind of annoying
especially when you have you know not
one triangle but let's say a million
which is not all that uncommon these
days so we use something else called
super sampling where you put lots of
samples inside the pixels and then you
get you know in this case 16 shades gray
possible per pixel and that sort of
looks okay unfortunately now you're
doing 16 times more work so they
invented something called multi sampling
where you only apply the the dense
sampling on the pixels that need it and
it looks like this now you you'll notice
in the middle of the shape you know
we're doing traditional sampling which
means there's no anti-aliasing there
which means it'll is going to look ugly
and then distorted like before so for
that we use other things like the
anisotropic filtering that I showed
before and the what you end up
approximating and sampling is something
more like this where this looks more
like a spinning triangle and then the
jagged one before which just skipped
around now if you try to think of this
in the the pure vector world without
sampling this is going to look something
like this which is a triangle that's
rotating smoothly surrounded by one
pixel white gradient and you can see
that because of the sampling this is
where the sort of shades of grey
Stairsteps comes from as these gradient
transitions underneath the the sampling
grid and whenever you have any sort of
filtering technique whether it's a
Gaussian blur or mipmapping or an
anisotropic filter you're basically just
blurring your information before
sampling it to make sure that the slope
of your color information does not
exceed the limit that you
represent now just for completeness I
mentioned this WebKit font smoothing
which is you know a lot of people have
issues with this and turn it off because
Apple kind of did something stupid and
uses different filter that makes a font
look darker but it's just you know it's
sampling on a sub pixel grid doing red
green blue separately and the thing is
pixels are really dying or are dead but
they've been reborn because pixels are
dead as a design unit because everything
is scalable now and even though I'm
supposed to be supposed to be talking
about WebGL
all of this also really applies to CSS
now because your iPhone your your
zoomable browser is a GL scene and is
defined in vector world not in raster
world and not just pixels but any sort
of information in geometry for example
this height map which I'm generating
procedurally and that's that's a
different talk is defined on a grid and
you know you have to think of this as
sampled information that you're
processing now you can see here I'm
tuning the knobs on this generator to
make it oscillate in an interesting way
and you can see that I've added water
and you may be wondering how does it
know which part should be blue which
parts should be green is it for example
taking the surface that I've defined and
and cutting out the parts that are
underwater is it doing something else
well it's actually quite simple and it
turns out that samples are both the
curse and that's and the blessing the
problem and the solution because we use
something like that your sample isn't
just color it can have additional
information associated with it for
example depth we use something called a
Zed buffer where for every pixel in your
image you just record the depth as a
number in this case represented as a
shade of gray and whenever you draw
anything you update your depth map along
with it so that you know is the thing
that I'm drawing closer or further away
than what's already there and so you can
do per pixel cutting out of shapes that
intersect without actually knowing
anything about the geometry involved
it's it's a sort of very dumb but very
effective way of doing it and that turns
out to be what GPUs are great out
because this is massively parallel
izybelle
and aside from depth for example you
might also record orientation in the
form of normal which is a vector I'll go
into that more later for example for
something called deferred lighting where
you you generate an image like this and
then you paint the light in afterwards
using only this information so you stop
knowing what is outside the frame of the
picture you don't even know what it
represents all you know is that you have
a grid of samples with depth and normal
and color that you then used to do
lighting with so next step is the part
where you learn linear algebra and that
might you know send heart rates spiking
a little bit but don't worry because
we're going to do fun stuff with images
let's start with something called the
affine transforms which you would know
as the transform tool from Photoshop or
illustrator and those transforms include
rotation scaling and skewing and they
have something in common what they have
in common is that they all preserve
parallel lines no matter how you combine
them and that's a very useful property
because it means you can describe the
entire transform just by saying what it
does to the grid so you have you can
describe the grid using something called
a vector basis which is just your X unit
and Y unit represented as an arrow in
this case and because vectors are arrows
we can sort of do math with them and
that's that's essentially linear algebra
but let's forget about the numbers for a
second and just do it on paper and
suppose for example that I define a new
vector basis and I give you two
arbitrary arrows and I say tell me what
the smiley face looks like after it's
been transformed or let's start with
just that one point in purple see what
it looks like or where it should be and
that's easy because you decompose it
into its X and Y coordinates and then
you reassemble it on the other side
using the new grid and
because vectors are arrows you can also
scale them not just add them together
and that means that using this procedure
of disassembling and reassembling you
can find out where any point is after
it's been transformed just by using your
vector basis and if you get this then
congratulations you get matrices because
these mysterious grids of numbers that
they threw at you in school and that
they never really wanted to explain are
really simple they're the coordinates of
the blue and the green dot that just
describe where the grid has moved to
when you're done transforming and so the
column on the left is just the x
coordinate y coordinate of the blue
points the right the green numbers are
the X&Y coordinate of the Green Point
the reason you put them in a matrix is
because that allows you to do the
computations effectively in this case
something called the matrix vector
multiplication which is just
transforming a point to conform to a new
grid and it looks like this when you
write it out and so again you do this
procedure of disassembling this case
literally cleaving your matrix into two
and multiplying it by the two
coordinates of the point that you're
interested in in this case transforming
the red point into the purple point
transforming a circle into an oval and
then if we want to for example apply
another transformation let's say a
rotation we find that our vector basis
has just moved to a new location which
means there's just a new matrix and this
is where where matrix math gets really
interesting because if you do the naive
solution to this problem you apply two
transforms as in the bottom and you know
for every transformation that you pile
on you have to do another matrix
multiplication but because of the
properties you can condense them all
together and end up just optimizing in a
way into a single transform and that's
sort of the secret as the Y computer
graphics can be fast because you can
condense the relationship and the
placement of objects into just a single
mathematical object of a constant size
namely a matrix and this works in 2d but
it also works in 3d so a 3d image
is just a set of three vectors this case
red green blue that define an
orientation in space and in the matrix
you end up with three columns of three
coordinates and again you do a matrix
multiplication to transform in this case
the flat smiley face into a one that's
positioned in 3d and it also works in
four dimensions and that can be a little
weird
now why on earth would you do this
what's the point is what is the fourth
dimension well the key is actually in
the image which is four dimensions
projected back into 3d where suddenly
parallel lines are no longer parallel
which is interesting because that's what
perspective does and when you're
rendering in 3d often you want
perspective you want it to look natural
and that is why we use four dimensions
and I can't really show you four
dimensional math because picturing that
is kind of kooky but I'll show you how
it works for two-dimensional images
where you apply the third dimension to
do the same kind of trick so the reason
we use four dimensional matrix is to do
3d math is the same reason we use three
dimensional matrices to do 2d math and
it works like this you have ordinary
2-dimensional space a grid and that you
end up sort of doing a bat-signal thing
where you project it at word like this
and you apply so this is this is space
this is 3d and yet we call it
two-dimensional space why well because
the image that we're projecting is
two-dimensional and just like you know a
bat-signal projected onto a cloud the
delight along any particular Ray is
constant which means you only have two
degrees of freedom instead of three why
do we do this bill because what happens
when you start changing the vector basis
and in doing so we've gained a couple
new things for one we've gained a whole
new Zed vector the red one which which
didn't exist before we just made that up
and that's the interesting one because
if you move that one you aim the
bat-signal just like that and that means
that all of a sudden instead of just
being able to change
shapes in place we can move them around
as well which is something that affine
transforms couldn't do on their own so
you get translation and scaling effects
where if you pull out the the red vector
or push it in sort of changing its
length you end up tightening the beam or
expanding the beam and we have something
else which is that our x and y vectors
now also have a Z coordinate which until
now has just been zero and they control
the alignment of the the image because
if I change those for example tilting
them all the way back you see that you
tilt the image so that part of it is now
closer to the projection point part of
it is further away which ends up being
what perspective does so if you project
this back down to two dimensions now
your parallel lines are no longer
parallel and you you've done perspective
transforms and then that has an
interesting implication because it means
that if I'm drawing something like this
a cube in 3d space I can position and
move and orient it using a single four
four dimensional matrix and it has a
structure where in the upper left
portion there's a three by three normal
matrix that can turn that controls
rotation scaling skewing there's one for
translation which is you know shining
the the beam differently in four
dimensional space and then there's a Z
sorry in this case the W coordinates the
fourth coordinate d HL which controls
perspective and creates you know
narrowing lines effects and vanishing
points and that sort of thing and like I
said matrices can be condensed you know
applying five matrices in a row you can
express that as just one single combined
matrix which is very handy and that
means that the mathematical relationship
between that little black cube on the
screen and you know as its defined in 3d
space and the actual location on the
screen as its projected is defined by a
single matrix and and I can show you how
that works we start in object space
which is what you're looking at the cube
on its own
defined with its the the origin sort of
at its center of mass or if it's a
character usually you put it under their
feet it's just somewhere in the middle
so you have a point of reference you
transform object space into world space
by placing objects in with the matrix
matrix you can scale them rotate them
move them around etc and world space is
where everything else lives so in this
case I added a camera and I added a
ground plane so it has something to sit
on and world spaces again defined
relative to some reference point which
is the the frame that you're doing all
your your placement and simulation in
then we have another matrix
transformation that takes you to view
space which is a coordinate systems
centered on your camera in this case Zed
points forward but that's a convention
and you have to be careful which way
your axes points when you're doing these
things and finally from view space we go
into screen space which is simply pixels
and pixel units and so because we're
doing matrix transformations this entire
chain is ends up being implemented or
represented as a single transformation
and you can go backwards as well but
that's a little bit trickier finally I
just want to talk about shaders which is
how these things are actually
implemented on a graphics card say for
example you have a 3d model which in
this case is defined as vertices points
in space and triangles that span those
points so in terms of data structure
you're looking at a list of vectors
which define points and then a set of
indices saying you know triangle 1 goes
from 1 2 to 3 triangle 2 goes from 2 to
3 to 4 etc and that makes up this whole
object in object space and then we have
a program called a vertex shader that
just takes one vertex as an input and
outputs another vertex as output and you
can see that it's those are four
dimensional vectors that are coming out
and that that's because we're dealing
with the four dimensional sorry 3d
projective space
which has four coordinates and so this
transforms something called clip space
which I mentioned for completeness you
can just think of this as screen space
there's there's a sort of a difference
but it's not very interesting and then
the second part is we take these
coordinates into clip space which is you
know where is the thing on the screen
and then we turn it into samples and
then every one of those samples we apply
another program to which is the fragment
shader and that determines the color of
every pixel so on the left you see that
the light is changing the position of
the vertices isn't changing so only the
parameters of the fragment shader are
being tuned here not the vertex shader
the vertex shader is just constant at
this point so what does this look like
this is defining a language called GLSL
GL shading language and it's a very
simple program you can see that the main
function consists of one line in this
case which simply applies three separate
matrices to the position after taking
the the position and making it four
dimensional and there's this complicated
terminology here but it's really not
that hard
for example uniforms are just global
variables for example if you're trying
to draw an object and the object is red
that the fact that it's red is constant
everywhere so that's a uniform property
that you you set and then per vertex we
have something called attributes which
is the specific position of every point
and the at the end we set GL position
which is a standard variable - that
determines where on the screen you're
rendering and so this is this is like
your vanilla g GL pipeline but the point
is that this is just one possible way of
doing it you can do tons of things in
vertex shaders and and that's why
shaders have been sort of the main
driving force behind what's been going
on in games and in just offline 3d
rendering as well transforming shapes on
the fly on a sort of point by point
basis is a very powerful approach
because you can do it in parallel very
efficiently and then a fragment shader
looks like this for example again we
have uniforms
like say color and a direction of light
in this case and then we have something
called varying and then this is this can
be a little bit tricky to grasp but
basically our information at this point
is only defined on the corners of the
mesh so when you're trying to fill the
pixels in the middle you need to have a
way to transform that information and
you can just you know assume that it's
constant across the entire triangle
which makes it uniform or you could have
a property that's varying that varies
and the way that works is you just
define it at the corners and the
graphics hardware interpolates it for
you fills out the part in the middle and
then what this fragment shader does is
determines how how much the surface
should be lit by doing something called
a vector dot product which you can look
up and see what that does
and then multiplies that intensity by
the color of the surface and so this is
again the simplest possible fragment
shader in fact what's going on on the
left is actually a little bit more
complicated because it has something
called specular light which is sort of
that the glossiness that I didn't even
bother to implement in the code on the
right and so here's an example of for
example a vertex shader that does some
real work this is skeletal animation and
the way you have to think about this is
the model of in this case this
cyberdemon from doom 3 is just defined
statically and usually they even put it
in a sort of Vitruvian Man pose so it's
nice and neutral and then they feed in
the orientation of all the bones in the
skeleton every point is linked to a
point on the skeleton and by tuning the
knobs by changing the matrices you can
animate this character and this is all
done on the GPU on the graphics hardware
not on the CPU side an example of a
fragment shader that is very common is
normal mapping and so you see that all
of a sudden it seems like this model has
become way more detailed and that's an
illusion because the geometry hasn't
changed all I'm doing is I'm applying
something called a normal map which
tells the describes the orientation of
the surface and so I'm cheating because
it looks like it has tiny bumps and
little crevices and all that but it's
it's painted on
in a way that changes the shading so
it's not just a texture it's it's
information that is being splattered
onto a model interpolated and and used
to do the lighting on a per pixel basis
and because this is such an easy trick
we don't care about depths as much as we
do about light and shadow this is a very
effective way of creating the appearance
of hundreds of thousands of triangles
when really there's only a couple
thousand and you combine that for
example with a color map texture and
then there's something else called a
specular map which determines which part
of this creature are glossy in which
parts are metal or soft shaded and you
end up with something like this which I
think looks pretty damn cool
we're not done yet I'll just show you
one more trick that you can do with
fragment shaders so here I've put a
floor of bricks underneath the monster
and the bricks are being normal mapped
so that means that as I move the lights
above it you can see that the lights
that have catches the edges of the brick
and then it looks like they have depth
but that's an illusion because if I put
the camera at a glancing angle you can
start to see that it's fake that there's
no actual depth here it's just sort of a
texture that happens to have convincing
shading but we can fix that we apply
something called parallax mapping and
suddenly it looks like these bricks
actually have depth and yet what I'm
telling the GPU to do is still just draw
a flat square how does that work why it
does this all of a sudden look like it
is correct and here's the secret I'm
going to lock the uniform that tells the
shader where the camera is so the shader
is going to think that the camera is
staying right here when when it's not
and I'm going to rotate to the other
side and now all of a sudden this
illusion is completely destroyed and you
can see if you look closely there's a
sort of distortion going on with the
texture where it is streakiness and and
and weirdness and so the point of this
effect is it distorts the texture of the
bricks in such a way that from your
point of view it looks correct in 3d but
it's really cheap it's it's completely
fake and so you can see that the the
silhouette at the top left for example
stays a straight line as far as the the
depth is concerned this is a completely
flat surface but it's such an effective
technique and here for example I'm going
to update the the uniform that controls
that tells it where the camera is and
all of a sudden the illusion is restored
and you get breaks that look real that's
pretty much it I just want to leave you
with a couple of things to look at in
case you like this and that's something
you might want to do arrow twist comm
which is Paul Lewis who has it's not
only a beautiful site but the articles
are really well-written and simple and
straight to the point
so check
it's mostly 3GS which is also what I use
I like using 3GS because it just takes
care of the boilerplate there is Inigo
classes site which is sort of like a
treasure trove of demo scene techniques
and and other interesting mathematical
things mr. doob is the author of 3GS has
a site full of demos and interesting
things that you can look at and ultra
Cape qualia is another person it was
their implementation and part of the
cyberdemon model that i used for this
presentation thank you very much
[Applause]